does this sound fair a biological male
swimmer shattering a New Jersey college
record but only after switching from the
men's team to the women's Megan Cortez
Fields swam on ramico Ramapo College
men's team for three years before moving
to the girls team this season as a
senior the school swim team recently
congratulating the transgender Athlete
on social media for breaking the school
record in the 100 yard butterfly but
later deleted the post citing the need
to quote protect their teammate from
insulting comments now you know Jessica
what's really amazing to me is that the
left the party of the Equal Rights
Amendment and choice is so willing to
allow women to be suppressed oppressed
and erased by men does that make sense
to you no it's I also don't feel that
it's accurate and I don't think that
this is a part a position of the left
over 70% of Americans don't think that
on the competitive level that people who
have transition and we should be clear
that the swimmer has met the ncaa's
criteria in terms of uh estrogen so the
hormone therapy has gone through but
this is an area where there's vast
agreement it is so different from gender
affirming care for young kids um but I
don't see this as a leftist policy I
just think it's insane what do you think
Jesse is this a leftist policy well no
because now Emma and I are interested in
it we did some Financial Planning and
for Jesse Jor to do a 4year stin at
University it's going to cost about
$450,000 so we're going to be
transitioning Jesse right into the high
school where he will be in the fall
playing field hockey swimming in the
winter and softball in the spring
three-letter athlete identifying as a
woman he'll be going as Jessica and then
he will be getting a full ride to a
division one school where he's going to
shatter every single female record and
you're not going to be able to do
anything about it Jessica how dare you
how don't don't even start don't even
start okay Dana um you know they the
left talks about fairness for all and
and you know everybody coming out equal
but this is about discrimination I think
so I mean you asked is this unfair I'm
like it's clearly unfair it's outrageous
I also think it's completely
uncomplicated like I'm not going to talk
all of these other words that people
want to use about this like this is not
complicated for me this is outrageous
and I cannot believe that there are so
many women in power who either have been
professional athletes who have made a
gazillion dollars and they're fine
they're retired and and they were in
women's sports and they were the
pioneers and women's sports and they
will not stick up for these girls who
are their opportunities are being taken
from them money is being taken from them
they have decided just to talk about
quiet quitting that's exactly what these
girls do and imagine being the woman
with the most power in the United States
KLA Harris the first woman vice
president and she will not say a word to
stick up for these girls I think is
appalling you know what we should do put
all guys on
outnumbered one guy surrounded by four
trans guys right how would you like that
okay you're the one lucky guy yeah last
word Brian my last word will be quick I
always say to myself in complicated
times in sports how does Cricket uh
decide what to do and I led I looked
that up and Cricket banned all
transgender women from playing
international cricket I think you just
make it say listen we're not doing this
yeah it's very simple uh whatever
however you were born you can compete
we're just not going to count you and
and then we going to got first four and
then the first woman comes in first the
first transwoman get the first trans man
can do what he wants but you're just not
allowed to compete okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else